[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality author of the number
one bestseller proximity principal
and host of the ken coleman show where
he talks
about your career talks about you
getting the right
job talks about you living out your
passions and we're going to talk about
that today with you along with anything
else you want to talk about
the phone number here is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two
five five two two five ricardo
is in charlotte north carolina hey
ricardo how are you
hey dave how are you great man what's up
all right yes so right now i'm currently
21 year old
um i have 35 000 saved in my bank
account
um i'm currently in college but um i'm
doing like debt free because i'm getting
some
help um and then i'm currently living
with my parents
i've been thinking about moving out but
i realize when i move out i'm
basically going to be like pit living
paycheck to paycheck
so what do you think i should do when
will you graduate from college
um next year okay well it's not unusual
for someone to live at home until they
graduate from college
but if you're 28 you make 60 000 a year
in your mother's basement there's issues
dude
oh no i'm sorry i'm sorry i know you're
not you're 21 you live at home you don't
make any money you're going to college
you've got 35 000 savings i got it
that's not you my point is you're what
you're doing is a fairly normal process
and it's not
does not indicate that you're
emotionally stunted
yeah yes um ricardo you're overthinking
this
you're in great shape you got a year
left i'd absolutely stay if it were me
is there a relational problem at home um
there is kind of a little bit i
actually do work full-time as well um i
make 14
an hour and um i'm actually doing like
this
you know on like the regular shifts and
everything
um but there is a little bit of problems
but i think we're finding a solution to
it
so yeah what are you studying
um i'm doing business administration
good for you
and where'd you get where'd you get the
35 000
the what's right where did you get the
35 000
i've worked at several jobs during
couple years now
and that's how i said i'm pretty i'm
pretty good with budgeting i'm pretty
good with numbers
i love budgeting and doing all these
things
i don't think you're living paycheck to
paycheck i think you you've
misunderstood that phrase because you're
actually so conservative and so
disciplined you've got 35 000
in the bank and you're working full-time
and going to college uh debt free
i think you just came out with doubt he
would be that's what he said
yeah because he'd be using up all of his
14 dollars just to pay just to pay rent
so uh
who paid for college um so it was um
i like my own family's coming from a low
income
so i'm using my i'm health i'm i got
help from caspa which is
um it's like you don't have to pay it
back it's like government assistance
so you got pell grants yes pell grant
yes
okay all right because that's the only
one you don't pay back the rest of them
fafsa signed you up for makes you think
it was a
grand and it turns out it was a student
loan so um
yeah but okay now if you unless you have
a toxic i mean a really nasty bad
situation that you've got to get out of
there
i'm going to suck up whatever the
relationship thing is be humble
and finish my time there get out of
school graduate with 35 000
in the bank and a degree in business and
go get the
big boy job and uh move out then so that
means you're only there one more year
um yeah that's what i would recommend
and if you were my kid that's what i
would
ask you to do to continue to do that um
but as you said it sounds like there's
some
rough spots you guys need to smooth out
in the rules of the house and when you
live in someone else's
house you live by their rules yeah and
also he's a number cruncher where i was
going is it you know could you get a
roommate let's see
what what that looks like what does your
paycheck allow you to do and could you
get a roommate and maybe still do it if
not
as you're pointing out he's got a year
he's going to save up even more than the
35 thousand
living at home so he's going to be in
fantastic shape yeah you'll be able to
move out pretty easy with a
good solid job and and with the graduate
you know the new job after graduation
that
should be considerably more than 14 an
hour should put you in that position
so yeah it's um this is an interesting
age group
yeah we're talking to them you and i
both on the ken coleman show on serious
exam and
but youtube is drawing in this 19 18 19
20 21 22 year old
bunch and you know used to that if we
had someone call
and they said they were living at home
they were 28. oh yeah and so we
immediately jumped ahead and said
yeah come on you know but in this case
but we're having a lot of young people
who are go-getters yep that uh
i mean i'm talking to 19 year olds with
substantial dollars that are calling in
here and
they're doing these substantial things
so they're a portion of that generation
whatever the label is that's on this
uh 18 to 24 year old generation whatever
that's not millennials certainly but
i don't i don't know the proper
demographic gen z or mosaics is what
they call them
z was before millennials wasn't no it's
after is it i promise okay well you
probably know more than i do
you do it's what oh you mean oh no no
yeah x was x is me i'm j x well i know
that
but and so then it's more like between
um z i thought it was
x i thought it was x z millennial but
what do i know obviously i don't know so
here
bottom line is this age group
there is a very serious group of them
yes i don't know if there's a bunch of
deadbeats in there too i don't talk to
them
but they're watching the ramsey show on
you
youtube and are calling in and that guy
right there
when i was 21 oh yeah and 35 000. not
even close
i don't even know how to say 35 000 you
know and one thing i want to point out
right now ricardo he's still listening
in ricardo i would challenge you to look
for
a job that pays more than 14 an hour
over the next year or so
because right now we're seeing companies
not the federal minimum wage but
companies are raising minimum wages
because there is
right now so many jobs that are open and
people aren't returning
now is the time in a metropolitan area
like charlotte north carolina ricardo as
sharp as you are
i would at least challenge you to look
to not maybe you could find something in
the 17
18 20 an hour you'd be surprised what
companies are offering to try to get
talent
just stable talent in the door well they
might want to move you in there
into a business type job with your
business degree almost come
yes sir it's almost like a paid
internship because they know you're one
year away from diploma
so i'd encourage him to do that as well
and then to what you were saying dave we
know this from the data there's recent
studies out
that this generation this gen z they're
they're in high school now they're in
their early 20s
more than any generation previous in
america
they are more entrepreneurial they are
thinking when they come out of high
school
that they're going to eventually own
their own business some want to go right
into it not even into college
and those that are going into college
are thinking i'm going to college
because i want to work for me
one day we're seeing that big time and i
think we're seeing that reflected in
in the kids that are watching our show
well that's gonna change the political
landscape
yes it will wait till they start seeing
the taxes come out yeah
yeah well not among other things yeah
and all the other policies
trying to run a business with the
government breathing down your neck yeah
but the uh
very good point that's a very good point
wow interesting labor market right now
yeah very cool
very cool ken coleman ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show on siriusxm
an
ever popular podcast and of course 75
radio stations plus
carrying it now you can tune in and hear
him anytime
he's my co-host today this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
open phones at 825-5225
smart dollar is our best money content
and products products packaged digitally
and tailored for the workplace companies
offer smart dollar to their team
as an employee benefit people like
costco for instance have had all their
employees go through our materials
teaching them
and lots of companies of all sizes big
companies small companies everything
have figured out that if their employees
are out of debt and on a plan
and concentrating they're able to
concentrate at work then
even the folks in the military know
mission readiness is affected by
money stress and so getting rid of money
stress increases productivity and all
that
and one of our smart dollar customers is
um
a company called forever lawn and
they've been a customer for a long time
heidi is with us
in canton ohio from forever loan lawn hi
heidi how are you
i'm a great dave thank you how are you
and ken
better than we deserve so i'm
i'm looking on my notes here that the
smart dollar team gave me
and it looks like you you got the team
through
your team through smart dollar before
covet hit
just because you wanted to help your
team members i'm guessing you had a
little different covet experience with
people who had their act together
we did it was uh it was it definitely
gave people time to think about their
finances their futures their
their goals and to be really intentional
about their budgeting
yeah and so when you know when did you
guys have layoffs or furloughs or
anything
we did not no we had we kept everyone on
staff
excellent how many team members have you
all got well we have about 70 at our
home office and then we have about 70
dealerships across the country
cool what's forever lawn do what do you
all do
great question so forever lawn is a
premium artificial grass company
and we have five premium artificial
vertical brands foreverland landscape
golf green sports grass canine grass and
playground grass
and we service people throughout the
country
uh with whatever needs they would have
um to
make their lawns their yard their homes
uh a place where they can enjoy
ken i think you need a putt-putt green
out back out of this artificial stuff
i'm thinking yeah i'm thinking you need
to install one of these i do and i'll
tell you something else i had two big
doodles and so i've actually sampled
their product
no way yeah so here's the deal i spoke
for them a couple years ago because of
entree leadership
oh they sent a sample of this canine
grass dave and it's
brilliant the doggy can go out and do
their business on it
and it doesn't kill your grass it goes
through it filters through it's
fantastic so you have this beautiful
lawn all the time
and it's healthy for the dog it's
brilliant
oh my gosh because you know dogs can do
a real number
where are they thank you thank you they
thought i was going to get specific for
a second no not at all
but it's fascinating too late you've
already overshared yeah so
when you guys when you guys put your 70
team members through pre pandemic
what kind of insight does that give you
how important it is post pandemic
for folks to have their employees go
through and learn how to get out of debt
and budget
and kind of just be ready for life
because your guys weren't not as freaked
out about the possibility
of layoffs they had to be and they had
ken coleman speak to him so i mean
they were completely prepared and ready
right
yes absolutely uh they definitely
helped to like you were mentioning the
financial stress uncertainty frustration
um looking for answers you know just
worrying about money
uh definitely they were able to put
their feet to the ground
and just go at it so the
the worrying the not knowing um
definitely was not there for our team
yeah
okay so when you launch this thing and
you say okay we got a dave ramsey
financial
class for smart dollar for the team did
they like go oh gross
or were they like engaged or excited or
how hard was it to get them to do it
um well at first i will tell you you
know i think anything with
financial when you're talking about
financials sometimes it's hard for
people to
um you know open up including myself you
know just be
vulnerable willing to talk about your
finances
um to just get real about it so at first
i think
uh you know just it getting going um
people were a little bit um you know
they wanted to be able to join in
but i think sometimes it takes the power
of a team and other people
joining in and um cheering them on uh
you know makes it more of something
everybody wants to be a part of because
we all have the same
uh challenges and the same uh you know
outlook on things and want to have a
financial path for our families to
that gives us freedom so i i think that
that
now that they've all quickly left now
that they've all been through it what
are they saying
oh my goodness they absolutely love it
uh we have
i mean i mean if you want to hear
directly from team members i have some
quotes from them but we
everyone i think that has been a part of
it and has chosen to join it has
been a great impact in their um in their
own personal lives
whether it be um you know in saving
paying off debt um
you know paying off houses um to just
even setting up their budgets for the
very first time
so i want to ask because that's an
amazing uh list of personal testimonies
but how have you seen it lift
professional performance in the in the
culture and in the workplace
great question i definitely think that
the the weight
that many feel of you know do i think a
lot of times we ask
ourselves when we're in that stress or
that situation where we don't know about
our money and we don't know
you know where it's going or where we're
going to be we start asking questions
like should i look for another job even
though
i've heard that from people and they
absolutely love you know they love being
here but still like should i go look for
a job that has
uh you know that offers more money and
when we really take a look at it and
everybody gets personal about it you
realize it's not
about making more money it's about um
you know
telling your money where to go the money
that you do have and then you can
you can do whatever you want to do as
long as you have that mindset
that's huge that's great retention
strategy oh yeah it's everything
that's everything so we've got all this
detailed in-depth research
that shows that when a company like
yours spends
money to invest money to
teach their team that the net result is
is that they they get a return on
investment meaning they
get that money back and more in saved
retention
in uh you know lowered stress increased
productivity and so forth
have you guys actually i mean research
is one thing but now i'm actually
talking to somebody did it
uh are you you know and you're running
the place are you looking at your team
going
as a business person this investment
paid off
oh yes absolutely i think from multiple
people and even for myself
we definitely look at it as um you know
we've been given this
this amazing tool and this opportunity
and so you you
want to you know that the owners who
invested in this
they don't it's not just about the
everyday business they truly care
and are intentional about wanting the
best for you you personally
um and your family and your life so it
goes beyond the workplace
um you know they truly value you know
everything
outside of just these walls here at
forever lawn so i think that's that
speaks of volume
to people because they know that it's
not just about being here or the
paycheck that
they know they're taking care of and
that and that they're valued
very cool well heidi thank you for
taking your time with us we appreciate
you taking a minute out of your day and
talking about this very good stuff
and thanks again for uh having ken over
for uh sending him pet grass
and uh for teaching smart dollar to your
whole team thank you god bless you
thank you you too all right that's heidi
from forever lawn
um you know we've got high school
curriculum that's in 48
of the high schools a lot of people
don't even know that we've got this huge
corporate initiative yes that is a large
section of our business
but it's since it's business to business
the public a lot of times doesn't know
it's there so uhr directors out there
uh you decision makers inside of
businesses if your team is out of debt
and on a budget
they're not taking calls from mastercard
during the day
learning who the master of their life is
guess what they're focusing on work
it's a neat thing productivity goes up
stress goes down wow
heidi said they don't look for other
jobs they stay with you
that's a great leadership strategy if
you're a small business owner ding ding
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt free stage
kevin and katie are with us hey guys how
are you great how you doing
welcome where do you guys live clinton
township michigan
okay and that's near it's about 20 miles
north of detroit oh okay
cool well welcome to nashville good to
have you guys
fun and all the way down here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
uh 90 000. all right how long did this
take 15
months good for you and your range of
income during that time
uh we started at 215 000 uh
then i took a pay cut it dropped down to
uh during the pandemic it dropped down
to 195
and then afterwards i went back up to
225.
excellent what do you guys do for a
living i am a cpa in industry
and i'm a teacher all right what do you
teach second grade
all right fun good for you guys what
kind of debt was the 90 000
uh it was a little bit of everything we
had uh
student loans uh car loans we had a
camper loan
we had uh 401k loan credit cards
you were normal yeah you're normal and
normal socks
yeah that's so what happened what i mean
how long y'all been married
25 years okay so so you're going along
and you're just
living the american nightmare and paying
everybody
money and working and no money to show
for it what woke you up
so um you know we i we've been in debt
our entire life yeah
um and
we uh what would you say
um i i uh
i kind of froze here well he came across
your book um and was telling me about it
and to be honest
i didn't see a problem and i wanted
nothing to do with it um i didn't
we we were normal everybody's in debt is
what i thought
everybody is you're right and so
probably i don't know let's say three
years ago
he said um hey you know dave has a
daughter rachel
i i you should probably you know listen
to her check it out
yeah she yeah i i told i was i was
watching your shows you know
um trying to figure out a way to get out
of debt uh to not be normal and
i brought you up to her and she wasn't
interested at all
yeah but rachel got through right rachel
i started watching her podcast
uh following her on social media one day
i was going through
filing you know shredding things and i
saw our credit card statements
when they came in the mail i just passed
them off to him i never opened them and
when i saw the numbers and i saw the
receipts
i i knew there was a problem and so
we started our budget which to be honest
i hated
that the first few months i fought him
um
and because i felt like the budget was
telling me i couldn't spend anymore
i didn't see it as giving me permission
to spend it was telling me i couldn't
and then the pandemic hit and we went
through financial
peace university online wow and um
that was eye-opening that is what
changed me right then and there oh wow
it all made sense and a week later
i went to my husband and handed on my
credit card and the look on his face was
shocked
and shocked and loved yeah
i'm in love with this woman and and then
she asked me if i want to do a budget
too
oh my god how sexy is that cpa budgets
are
my friend right that's so funny i just
couldn't get through to her
you know how that to share the budget to
do the budget together
i was always doing everything myself
yeah okay you know as as the super nerd
so katie it sounds like i don't want to
read into this too much you tell me if
i'm wrong but it sounds like
uh the fact that you didn't have full
knowledge of how bad it was was part of
your
uh i guess the
reason a valid reason that you weren't
worried about it exactly
you know he took all the care of all our
financials when we got married i turned
over all families
if he had sat down and said hey i need
help and laid it all out in front of you
you would have been gone
oh my god yeah which is actually the net
of what happened right
right yeah you know once you saw that oh
my gosh he's carrying this and we gotta
i got i gotta get i can't do but yeah we
gotta do this that's so fun cool and we
went through some tough times too she
katie was diagnosed with breast cancer
um was it 10 years ago
13 13 years she's she's in remission now
so i mean we got to do a lot of tough
things and
this is just one more tough thing that
we finally did yeah
yeah well yeah this is nothing compared
to that but uh but at least you knocked
it out in 15 months
90 000 worth how's that feel no payments
it's awesome wonderful it's been my
dream for probably
15 20 years you know so i gotta ask so
you come to him with the credit card and
the budget request and he's stunned
he's fired up right as he just shared
what was the gazelle
first gazelle move or were there a
couple of big moves how'd you guys just
really dive into it what'd that look
like
um i think the still the first few
months it was kind of slow sure
um and then um it was in
the summer of last year that's when
gazelle i
i didn't see the progress and i was
getting really really frustrated and i
was wondering why was it taking so long
to get out of debt
and um so i i think that's when i
wanted to kick it into gazelle intensity
and we just looked at that budget again
and
looked at what other areas can we cut
what else can we do
um one of the biggest things actually
that happened
which you think is a bad thing is my
daughter was driving a car and it got
totaled
while it was in the middle of pandemic i
didn't have to go to work we didn't buy
another car so we took that insurance
money and
paid off a big chunk there's a big one
okay but no your daughter's carlos
yeah we've bought we have bought a used
car
good good good good good yeah she would
not be a happy camper yeah that's good
all right so what do you tell people now
that you both have done this
and you're the other side of it all the
the the weaving and bobbing to get to it
but then when it was game on
what did you do to pay off 90 000 in 15
months what's the keys
for me it was the budget um and the
every dollar
app and being involved in the process um
and the communication with
my husband especially the everydollar
app because
she could see where we're at and see all
the details
very cool but a patience is a huge key
also because
you know i i i could see where we were
going when we'd be paid off but
just waiting and waiting was probably
that there's a grind to go with the
hustle
yeah it goes they go together so when
you're in financial peace university how
far down into the class were you before
you were completely like okay game on
i was before we started yeah that's true
that's true
uh i want to say after the second class
okay yeah right
and then i don't know what class number
it is but when you talk about
um investment because at that point i
was
clueless about that and after watching
that episode
i was like this makes sense and i know
where we want to go and i know where i
want my money
wow so very cool well that's inspiring
thank you
i'm getting ready to write some of that
stuff again and we're going to do
another uh we
constantly are adding to financial peace
university and updating it
as well and reshooting some of those
lessons and i've got some reshoots this
summer so
that inspires me to work on that thank
you god bless this is very cool you guys
and you brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages
so we have uh elizabeth 23
23 and uh charlie he's uh
17. we have another one at home but he
couldn't come because he's actually
working
and then we have zach here who is
elizabeth's uh boyfriend
oh okay well welcome you guys good to
have you guys we got a copy of
uh the legacy journey because that's the
next chapter in your story to leave a
legacy change a legacy it's what you've
done
and a copy of the total money makeover
so you can pay it forward and give that
to someone and start their journey
because once people start hearing just a
little bit of your story they're going
to want to know more
and how to do this very well proud of
you guys your heroes
good job very very nice all right it's
kevin
and katie beth ben charlie and
zachary zach okay sorry about that and
ninety thousand dollars paid off in 15
months making 215 to 225 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're dead
[Applause]
game on baby this is how you do it
financial peace university almost
10 million people have been through that
class now it's part of ramsey plus
be sure you check it out you can get a
free trial on it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we talk about your life your
money your career
your job your income the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five matt's in seattle hey
matt how are you
i'm doing good how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
so um i have a question about the
long-term care
insurance question that's coming up in
washington
basically there's a new tax coming in
place next year 0.58
of every hundred dollars with no income
income maximum
is going to be collected so my wife is
37
i'm 34. we can opt out if we purchase a
private plan
but we feel like that's also quite
premature so i just wondering if you
could help me determine
what direction we should go opt out one
time option
or just suck it up and pay the tax matt
i'm a little bit
behind the curve here i'm not aware that
that has actually passed
it's passed it starts uh in january 2022
and all the employers here sent out
letters about the one-time opt-out
option
federal or washington this is washington
state only
oh okay all right because i'm thinking
how did i
miss that on the federal level okay um
no i'm not aware of that okay so they
have passed a law
oh my god what is wrong with your state
um
taxing you if you don't buy long-term
care insurance
well essentially if you pay into this
program for 10 years
you qualify for 36 000 of
long-term care coverage which is barely
a drop in the bucket
um and for us being so young we're
wondering if
if we paid private insurance if those
premiums would be so low that it would
be just better that we have
that um which is guaranteed and it's
portable
so if we leave the state or you can so
you either pay the tax
um and buy the plan
or you have to have a private plan one
of the two
correct but you're automatically
enrolled in this bad plan
if you don't buy a private plan correct
and you can only opt out one time
um before this starts in january
so this is like a one-time option for us
to consider
otherwise we have to pay it
freaking communist yeah um
wow uh
if i just a little more information
might be helpful right so
um our gross income is about 220 000
for our household so we probably be
paying about
you know 12 to 15 hundred dollars for
this
program i'm not sure what we would have
to pay
given our ages for a private plan for
those premiums
yeah i hear this one
plan we could take it with us anywhere
yeah yeah and it'll be much better
quality because i'm sure the state
provided service is not going to be to
the level of the
private provided service it never is
just think dmv
um so this is the problem with socialism
um here i got two things running through
my head
one is there's a math problem and two
there's a philosophy problem
that i have if i'm in your shoes and
that's how i have to answer the
questions if i woke up in your shoes
okay okay so i'm opting out just because
i'm pissed off
right and then i got to figure out how
dumb that was mathematically
and it wasn't dumb really uh it's
probably going to turn out to be
good for you overall um because there's
some probability maybe low that you
leave that state someday
and then you paid into this stupid thing
um
man that's just i'm surprised there's
not a court challenge on that
oh yeah i guarantee you there's
lobbyists a lot of people by surprise
oh yeah this is all behind the scenes
dealing i can tell you that right
smoking back rooms
um all right yeah so anyway all of my
whining aside
i'm opting out and i'm going to take the
private plan unless you can see
that it is dramatically like tens of
thousands of dollars different and i
don't think it is
i think it's hundreds of dollars you
make 200 000 a year
you want private care number one number
two you want
portable care and number three there's
some probability you don't live there
someday and you're not you haven't paid
in this plan that you would never use
uh which is the irony of the whole thing
so uh let's say it's what it's based on
so
yeah i i'm uh libertarian enough
economically
speaking that i'm going to run from any
government interference and government
control over my life
that i can legally were you shocked by
how low the third it was thirty six
thousand dollars he said drop in the
bucket that seems like a you're forced
into it then you have thirty six
thousand dollar limit towards your
long-term care
in coverage yeah which is nothing that's
what i'm saying it doesn't go very far
yeah it just doesn't make any sense
covers
one year um yeah even shocking
so yeah i'm opting out i'm opting out
because i'm philosophically against it
and because i think you'll work out
better long term mathematically
or close enough uh but you're gonna have
to dig into the numbers i'm not sure of
that because
you caught me a little bit flat-footed i
don't know the details
but with what you told me it sounds like
it's not that much different
a little bit more expensive on the
private side but given that your income
is so high
that's what's that's where they're
really tagging you this is a soak the
rich moment
again wow yep come on washington
unbelievable yeah this is the problem
uh when the nanny state comes in you get
you get bad products
uh created by high taxes yeah because
you need more money the government needs
more to pay for all these things they're
doing for people
this is nothing more than a disguise tax
that's all it is
wow with the promise of a benefit that's
not even a benefit oh
gross gross gross gross it's such a
pretty state too
yeah yeah so we'll have to call our
friend that lives there in seattle and
give him a hard time
as soon as i get off the air i'll be
sick absolutely let's blame it on him
i rag on him all the time anyway but
this is yet one more reason they just
beat him to snot that's just oh man
that's so sad
it's just so sad you know these um but
you
what you're seeing is yeah all right
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five i'm not going down the
rabbit hole i'm gonna resist the urge
tina's in birmingham hey tina how are
you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
okay so my husband recently got a job in
arizona
he's there now and i'm here in alabama
close enough on our house
we have to sell it first so we have to
somehow do an arizona tour trying to see
should we
rent or should we buy
okay are you out of debt um
the only thing we have is um a
car loan and it's 8000 that's what we
owe on it and so
how much you're getting out of your
house how much you're getting out of
your house when it sells
so we'll probably get about 60k out of
it good pay off the car
then that leaves you the rest for a down
payment minus an emergency fund of three
to six months
of expenses so if there is nothing wrong
especially in a market like we're in a
white hot real estate market
what part of arizona too fun
okay white hot no pun intended
it is very hot literally but also uh the
economy is so
um beautiful area though so i i i
there's nothing wrong with renting for
six months or a year
learn the town and you'll make a better
choice
it's hard to come into a city cold and
buy a house and know where the invisible
lines are i mean you're trusting a real
estate agent
you got to do a lot of research you got
to learn but the every town has
invisible lines meaning
across the tracks when you cross that
road
the same square footage house drops down
you know and it's just
it's location location location is how
real estate prices are established and
sometimes it's a little bit random as to
how that occurs
and so learning the market spending a
year researching and learning the market
will cause you to make better decisions
so i like the idea
of renting you know ken um i bought a
couple of properties this year
and in both in about several properties
this year but um
in every case except one
which was an adjacent property so i
already knew the property but i have
worn myself out looking at
options because i i learn the entire
market
i want to learn everything about it i
want to learn the per square foot
i want to learn all the nuances of the
micro market that it's sitting in
now i enjoy it because i love real
estate but when anytime you're making a
decision taking a job buying a house
options equal power that's absolutely
right what you're doing there is you're
getting really really clear
and what you just described gives you
tremendous confidence because you're
very clear on what the best choice is
and the best purchase
it's always better to go clarity clarity
clarity yep
gives you power and you make wiser
choices james childs is in
the booth and who's filling in for kelly
madison broward
madison is in there hey madison this is
the ramsay show
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman is
my co-host today ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show which you
can hear on 75 plus radio stations
series 6m and has a podcast all the time
talking about career talking about jobs
talking about
finding the place where you can function
in your highest
level at your highest level with your
talent your passion
and uh that's ken's thing so we're here
answering questions about that as well
as life and money the phone number
triple eight
eight two five five two two five max is
in des moines hi max welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave and ken thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh everything above eye level but that's
not why i'm calling
i got an email today i am a contractor
and got emailed today from my job and
i started 11 months ago and it's been
remote up until now and they want me to
start coming into the office starting
july 5th
in the last few weeks before this email
i've got the impression that
micromanagement might be a problem with
this job and uh
i've even actually put out a couple
applications just to see what was out
there
but with being at home uh the
micromanaging you know wasn't a huge
problem for me
my contract ends at the end of july but
it's renewable
should i wish it to be should i just
tell them
i'll stay at home through the end of my
contract see what they come back with
or do i go in for a while i look for any
job or
do i just flat out leave i'm in baby
step six i have a four month emergency
fund
um and that's about where i'm at
what email came on this morning i'm a
software engineer
yeah okay so what are you going to do
over the next five years with your life
i'm going to continue with
my software engineer position as a
contractor
i would rather be with a company um
i took this job uh because i lost my
previous job to covet and it was
out of desperation i was in debt at that
time
everything's really fallen in place with
this position
and i'm thankful for it
but i think it might be time to move on
and i just don't know um
which of those three routes that i
mentioned i should go
well i'll tell you this i think that you
uh
bite your lip and you go in there and
you deal with micromanagement
whatever that is whatever that looks
like and you do a great job and you're
looking elsewhere
because you want to move on from
contracting anyway to work for a company
and you stay with i don't want you to
use that emergency fund that's for
emergencies that's not for
job transitions and you've done a great
job baby step six
be patient right now and understand the
big picture
so if you've got some poor management
you can deal with that it's not an
abusive toxic situation
and so i would stay put until we have a
better step
another rung on the ladder a higher rung
on the ladder and keep moving up doing
the work you want to do the good news
you know exactly what you want to do
you're qualified you're in great shape i
would deal with this
until we find something better hold your
nose and go get a job while you work
there the last month that's what ken's
saying yeah
that's right so and here's the other
thing here's the other thing
you're extrapolating something here that
hadn't even occurred yet
i thought you might bring that up and
yeah that is true
and uh and i know how you feel about the
working from home gig
and it's really it's not that i'd be
willing no i didn't i didn't
i didn't hear you say that i heard you
say you had you thought you were working
for people that were going to be a pain
in the butt that's different i don't ask
anybody to do that
but uh but but uh and you know it might
be
worse than you think it's gonna be it
might be better than you think it's
gonna be
but probably it's not gonna be what you
think it's gonna be
it's probably gonna be better or worse i
mean that's fair that's a fair guess and
um yeah so
i think i i think your goal is to land
the new gig and your software engineer
you should be able to do that in 30 to
45 days by the end of the contract don't
you
uh i do i uh i've already got um
i've already got uh applications out
there
uh three applications out there and i've
just um contacted my recruiter and
she says she doesn't want to lose me so
she was hoping to find me somewhere else
possibly
well that's somebody won't put you back
in a contract role
true no thank you that's not your
long-term goal that's right
use this 45 days of holding your nose
to hit your long-term goal which is the
dream company
that you want to work for that's good
people
and it's good pay doing what you love to
do yeah
let's let's hit the let's grab the brass
ring baby
let's get the whole thing in the
transition you took this step back in
order to pay the debt because you got
kicked in the street due to covid
and now you've got the opportunity where
the market is swung completely in your
favor
to go land the perfect thing don't you
think i think he's in perfect position
only one other thing
you're assuming that a couple of things
you've seen over the last 30 days
mean micromanaging and you think it's
going to be worse because you're in
there i
i'm not sure i think micromanagers
micromanage people that are remote and
they micromanage people that are in the
office so
i think there's a little bit of a
monster under the bed thing here it's
not as bad as you think i agree with
dave
and this is this is temporary man i
would not tell you to go back if you
were saying i'm going to do this for the
rest of my life
correct you know or if you did i'd go in
there and say i'm going to give them a
test and say do i want to work here the
rest of my life for the next 30 days if
not i'm going to be out
but in your case you're just out yeah
because it's not what you want to do in
long term so
you know aim where you want to be five
years from now
and the worst place you hit is a little
short if you aim at nothing
that's what you're going to hit every
time so let's aim high yeah
and you know worst case is you miss and
uh but that's not going to happen i
think you're in a
primo market for a software engineer now
very cool hey thanks for the call james
is in san antonio hi james welcome to
the ramsey show
hi how are you doing dave better than we
deserve how can we help
well okay so i have a car i already have
a beer car
my wife has a reliable car so what i do
is i drive back and forth to work and
that's it
because there's no ac within the last
three months we've been thinking about
you know we need a new car
um and uh so i just don't know how much
to spend on it
um how much money do you have okay so
i have i have 34 000 in the bank
okay and 15 15 000 of that
is emergency fund and now my wife also
has a 5 000
loan um the the my
main also main concern too is i'm a
renter
and my main goal is to buy a house
within the next six years
um and so i'm just i'm fearful of
letting that money go
so i just don't know how much money to
spend on a vehicle either okay
we'll pay off the five thousand dollar
loan out of that 34 today
and go buy a five or six thousand dollar
car and then restart
your the other portion that's not the
emergency fund is your down payment fund
and let's start saving aggressively to
build that back up
okay no car payments no 5 000
loan when we're done with this
discussion okay yes sir
god bless you brother this is the ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're in debt it can feel like
you're constantly at war
with your freaking bills it feels like
the bills are winning
you might wonder if you can never get
ahead listen it doesn't have to be like
this you can pay off this debt you can
move ahead you can learn to handle your
money you can get control of it
and we'll show you how with financial
peace university
it's part of ramsay plush you can sign
up at ramsey plus
and you'll learn how to take control of
your money and
ditch your debt for good plus you'll get
all the tools that you need to make it
happen you can
get ahead you can end this constant
battle for your paycheck
you gotta take the first step start your
free trial of ramsey plus
that'll get you into financial peace
university and into the every dollar
premium
app among a bunch of other things text
trial for the free trial text trial to
33 789
text trial 233-789
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com a wonderful american company
blinds.com has a 100
satisfaction guarantee it means if you
measure mismeasure you screw up when you
order the blinds from them you get the
wrong color
it's your fault they'll still make your
blinds over for free
a lot of companies fix it if it's their
fault but this is if it's your fault
that's pretty cool you get free samples
free shipping
and with the new promos they run all the
time this great company will help you
save even more use the promo code ramsey
blinds.com today's question comes from
mustafa in california i'm a 14 year old
californian who is determined to become
a real estate investor and developer i'm
reading books about real estate
investing in economic cycles and i'm
focused
on getting an internship in high school
along with that future job i wanted to
know how you would go about pursuing
this career
if you were in my shoes or if you would
do anything differently well mustafa i
love this you are 14 year old who's on
the ball i love that you're going after
an internship in high
school and i would try to turn that
internship into any kind of job
entry level doesn't matter what it's
doing or how much it's paying
in high school and i would be focusing
on getting a job with a real estate
developer because what's happening is
it's a paid internship you are learning
the ins and outs
of the industry you want to be in from
somebody who's already doing it
the only thing i'd add to that is i
would literally be taking notes
whether it's on your iphone or with pad
and paper uh
pad and pencil and talking questioning
everybody customers uh people that are
working
and truly have that head on a swivel
dave i think a 14 year old doing that
early on
you're going to learn all the ins and
outs of being a real estate developer
and
should you change your mind it'll be
because of that experience you go oh
it's not what i
thought it was going to be but in this
case he's probably going to get a
master's degree
in just knowledge and wisdom from
soaking it up being a human sponge
yeah while you're doing that
look for old real estate developers
that's a great point some gray hair
because there's not many of them it's a
good point
real estate developers developing a
piece of real estate taking raw ground
putting a street sewers
infrastructure selling off the lots um
or or even putting in the buildings
whether it's commercial or residential
afterwards is the highest risk
of all real estate transactions
because you have it's a lot of money
number one number two
it takes a long time and you can get
caught sideways with an economic cycle
and so there are more people in the real
estate business
that have gone broke being developers
than any other category
more than being home builders more than
being real estate agents
more than owning real estate of other
kinds
so if that's your goal there's nothing
wrong with that but talk to some old
ones
that have figured out uh how to limit
the risk
uh how to uh be ready for the economic
swift
changes because otherwise you're gonna
talk to people who
have absolutely no concept of risk and
if that's all you learn
then you're going to learn some stupid
stuff that's going to put you in
in harm's way but you're i'm with ken
your concept you're dead on
i would go after it go do it obviously
you're
you're sharp young guy and you got some
got a real future ahead of you
bobby is in uh west virginia fairmont to
be exact hey bobby how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
uh yeah so i just recently actually
yesterday
sold my house so wow i have a
yeah so i have a hundred and ten
thousand dollar check that i
need some advice on what to do with i
don't have any debts
so my assumption is to invest in some
way but i really
i don't know where are you gonna live
much about that
in west virginia where i live now i
moved in with my girlfriend
um i've lived with her for about a year
so we decided it's time to
sell my house and since the market was
pretty hot i thought it was a good time
as well
okay so right now you're freeloading
yeah well i pay her with i pay half of
her expenses too and so i'm basically
renting from her
yeah so you have a roommate okay yeah
all right well when you get married
you're not freeloading anymore by the
way
right okay uh
what does your girlfriend owe on her
house
um she actually just refinanced it and i
think there's about a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars
um and what how much money do you make
i make just a little over a hundred
thousand a year mm-hmm
and what much how much money does she
make um
somewhere in the neighborhood of two
hundred thousand oh wow so three hundred
and ten
thousand dollar income three and ten
thousand dollar income you got a hundred
and ten thousand check in your hand and
she owes 160 on her house
uh do you have any other debt does she
have any other debt
uh no i mean well she has student loans
she is about 120
000 in student loan debt i have zero
debt
okay yeah you have zero debt of any kind
um
she makes more money than you uh but as
a as a married couple you guys are a
power couple with some student loan debt
to clean up and then a mortgage to pay
off
or if that were to happen right right
so what i would do is um
decide when you're going to get married
because if you get married this 110 goes
to clean up her student loans
then the two of you jump on this
mortgage with your huge income and knock
it out because it becomes your house at
that point
that you are sharing agreed right but
you don't do that with someone you're
not married to
you don't pay someone student loans
you're not married to you don't pay
someone's mortgage you're not married to
okay so for right now i'm parking this
money to the side
uh if you're if you think you're going
to get married within a year
or two i would just set it in a money
market account it's not fancy but it's
going to be available to execute the new
plan after marriage
but if you're gonna if you're not gonna
get married and you're just gonna hold
on to this money and she's gonna hold on
to her mess
then uh you probably ought to invest it
into some mutual funds
okay yeah but by the way you're gonna
end up homeless someday
with that scenario no real estate
and you're gonna end up using this money
to buy real estate at some point
okay when she kicks you out because you
won't marry her
or whatever happens yeah i'm glad you
said it i was going to say when are you
putting a ring on it man i know
i know that's what everybody's wondering
out there yeah so it's interesting
you got to lay out the uh
decision-making
paradigm here so let me ask you this
dave because
you laid that out so beautifully from a
relationship standpoint let's
we didn't ask him we didn't put him on
the spot but let's assume that they say
well we don't want to get married and
this comes down the way
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying i
mean this gets really interesting no
it's cause they're keeping separate
accounts but living together but they're
not married
yeah well we tell married people
combined yeah the problem is
is that they by
statistically okay the data tells us
that they're going to struggle to build
wealth trying to act like they're
married but they're not
right because it's two horses pulling in
two different directions that's what i
wanted and you don't pull the wagon you
just pull it apart
yeah you just destroy it that's all you
do yeah and so
that i mean that's the whole thing
because they're separate but they're
living together and
it's just this it just never gets
connected and i
that's the challenge with that well but
i mean and there's a there's all kinds
of research
yeah you know not picking on him but
just in general sure yeah
this says that as a married couple
there's what they call the marriage
advantage
it increases the success curve on your
on your career
your health and your finances
versus just trying to play house and yet
half of america now
is choosing not to be married but it's
it's problematic not just morally or
spiritually
but it's problematic from the data of
what happens in your life
this is the ramsay shot
[Music]
[Music]
well one thing we love to do on this
show are debt free screams
more than that free screams we love
doing debt-free screams on the debt-free
stage
in the lobby of ramsey solutions but
even more than that
we love debt free screams on the debt
free stage in the lobby of ramsey
solutions when it's one of our own
ramsey team members mike porter and his
wife kelly
from our own team here mike's one of our
systems engineers
in customer experience area and uh here
to do their debt-free screen
congratulations you two
thank you well done so how long you been
with us mike
uh six months okay wow so you're a
fairly new team member
yes you've come in uh came in kinda in
the uh towards the end of covid huh
that's correct or at least as ramsay
defines the end of kovat we yes
we got back to work faster than other
people dude i was going to say we were
six months ago
it's not the end of coving for other
people still so i guess that's true
but yeah but in other words you weren't
right in the heat of it but still six
months ago yeah it was still kind of
crazy around here
well welcome man very cool how much debt
have you two paid off
we paid off uh 247 thousand eight
hundred dollars
yo and how long did this take 55 months
okay man there is a story here and the
last eight months
six months is here at ramsey yes so what
kind of debt is this
uh it's everything we sold the house
we had two cars credit cards we had a
home improvement loan
a personal loan uh pretty normal stuff i
think
as society defines it yeah where's the
uh where's the house that you sold
in utah okay and that did you sell that
when you moved here for the job or
no actually we sold that um four years
ago
oh okay so it was we didn't explicitly
sell it as part of paying off debt
um but when we got ready to uh
move we were like we can't buy a new
house we're not
financially ready yeah and that was the
home improvement loan we had
the air conditioner go out and that's
what happens when you
don't have an emergency that's the way
it works you're asking for it yeah yeah
so the the t-shirts say debt-free what
uh because i
learned to say no
and her says because i listened to no oh
they are the opposite on the back what
does the back say nerd and free spirit
turn around turn around
all right debt free oh and oh and the
switches yes
oh i got it okay all right that's fair
that way kelly doesn't get all the trash
like you're the only one saying though
and she had to learn to hear it
yeah that's cool very cool way to go you
guys so tell us your story what happened
in your life
uh well uh we in uh 2016 that's when we
started
we did fpu
right before that i had lost my job in
2011 as part of the
aftermath of the whole housing bubble in
2008
and so i got a new job in 2011
took a pay cut i had actually by 2016 i
had
more than doubled my salary i got got to
it work hard
and we looked around and we looked at
each other and we weren't any further
ahead
i'm like i'm making more money and i'm
not ahead of where
we're not gaining any traction our son
at the time was a scene was just about
to go into a senior year in high school
and we had nothing saved so
we were we kind of looked at each other
we were like we have to change
something and we had some friends
back in utah who said hey we're doing
fpu and we kind of resisted it first
i know you've heard the line you know
oh we don't need fpu we can we can
afford all our payments
but when we really sat down with it we
really couldn't and we realized that so
we did fpu
and it really radically changed our
lives
learning to say no when we did fpu it
wasn't with rachel
uh leading but her her line that she has
in the new one
um which is um you know the budget gives
you freedom
gives you the freedom to say no but it
also gives you the freedom to say yes
because back when i taught it it was
just no yeah
[Laughter]
yeah then we got rachel to come along
and lighten things up yeah
but shut up shut up no yeah
and along the way um you know besides
paying off the the
that much we were able to cash flow
forty thousand dollars in tuition um
we've had
um over the last fifty five months about
thirty thousand dollars in medical bills
that we also cash flowed
plus moving across the country um and i
did
uh in march of last year i lost my job
and so i was without a job for two
months
oh my gosh um so all of those things and
in the that was in the middle of
it yes for sure anybody's measure yeah
and so you uh did you move to nashville
to take this job
yes okay all right from utah yes okay
very cool
very cool well we're happy you're part
of this team and we're very very proud
of you so
kelly what's the secret to paying off
248 thousand dollars worth of debt
me learning the word no oh it really was
it was really hard for me to sell my
house but when we got to that point we
said
we can either afford this house or we
can pay our debt
we don't need this house we bought a
house for a reason and it was to do
foster care
we had stopped doing that and we didn't
need that house anymore so i had to say
this house is no longer part of our life
and that was part
of our journey and then after that i had
to really learn
we don't need this we don't need this
and we don't need this
you know cutting loose that's an
emotional process
it really is hard and because it's you
know
in order for the next phase of your
dreams to happen the old ones have to be
pushed back
you know they're not there anymore and i
but you can't do both you can't leave
the old ones and the new ones
and that that's that is a that's a
that's a powerful thing you all did
there congratulations
very proud of you i got to ask you i
love to hear when the momentum happens
for people was it as a result of the
house and then you were able to
because you were really struggling with
that you say yes you sell the house
obviously that helped you what was the
big momentum moment or were there
several
in this journey there were several the
first one was our friends that led fpu
she told me about it and she said
told me what we needed to do and i said
but we can afford our payments and she
said
if you have to have payments you can't
afford it and that just hit me yes
grace beldack thank you um
she just told me the truth and yeah good
friends
wow and then the second one second
momentum kick after that you said mpu
was the first one
knowing that our son was going to go to
college and we had nothing safe he had
to go
yeah and we ended up being able to cash
flow
what he needed by saying no a lot to
other things so that we could pay his
tuition
rather than continue with normal mike
real quick what was the hardest thing to
say no to for you
um yeah we're both kind of spenders
um and and so for me it was
as we were doing foster care really um
coming when i'd come home from work
um she'd just be beat up from the kids
yeah um
and sometimes it was like hey can we
just go out to eat
yeah um you know because i don't feel
like cooking
and so having to sometimes say no to
that
and say you know i'll take the kids and
and we can relax for a little bit and
then you can cook
you know or i can cook
well either way i mean somebody's got to
do something here yeah wow
good for you well we're so we've got
folks that don't know we've got about
just 996 people on our team right now
and of those
roughly half our technology folks they
are
developers and uh systems engineers and
software engineers and
architecture folks and ruby on rails and
all the different things that
you folks do that i have no idea what it
is but uh um
so you're enjoying this technology team
it's it's fantastic
cool good stuff well we're very proud of
you guys
we're not going to ask your income
because we never do that with team
members that's not fair
because we've got half the company
standing out here to watch your debt
free scream
so we're not going to put you on the
spot in that way but everybody standing
here is proud of you we're proud of you
we're honored to have you on our team
sir we appreciate you being a systems
engineer with us and
i appreciate you kelly those are cool
t-shirts i like them a lot
so very very cool well done all right it
is
mike porter and his wife kelly he's a
systems engineer here on
ramsey solutions 248 000
paid off in 55 months what a journey
what a story count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
and the crowd goes wild i
love it love it way to go you guys
fabulous so proud of you this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today i am dave ramsey your host
this is the ramsay show you've heard us
talking about time shares for years
lately i've been doing some extra
special shows on timeshares
and what a ripoff they are but we we're
doing some research
we get the ramsey research team on the
timeshare industry and we want to learn
what's really going on out there
aside from my distrust and distaste
for them i want to know what's really
happening aside from their bs
lines that everybody loves them which is
a bunch of crap
somewhere in the middle is probably the
truth and so we're doing some surveys
and some research
if you'd like to participate if you're a
current timeshare owner or a former
timeshare owner
we're conducting a new survey where we
want your thoughts
your opinions on your experience
with time shares now we're going to do
this in a very sophisticated manner
to create a proper piece of research and
in addition to that we're going to just
let you listeners
speak into it and uh that way if
somebody tries to game it
like say the timeshare industry called
in and tried to game the survey
then we've got the two pieces of data
separate so we'll know that something
that there's monkey business so again
our research department they kind of
know what they're doing and make sure
that
they put all these stop gaps in there to
make sure that the data is
actually uh indicative of what's real so
how do you participate in the timeshare
survey you text
timeshare to 33 789 i would really
appreciate it
if you've ever been a time share owner
or an owner if you would take the survey
it won't take you about a minute
because we're really trying to learn
about you folks about the
about the public's perception and
understanding and experience with the
timeshare industry
i've got my opinions but i really want
to learn what's really happening
text timeshare to 33 789
one word timeshare 33789 and take the
survey
today mack is with us mac is in raleigh
north carolina
hi mac welcome to the ramsey show
hey how's it going dave better than i
deserve what's up
all right so i'm going into my junior
year
of college at app state university and
i have this money that i've been making
like over the summer
um for doordash i have like roughly
three to four thousand dollars just kind
of sitting in my bank account
um i'm just sort of curious like where
to go
um because i'm gonna be coming into
student loan debt
in about two years here i'm not quite
sure
like what to do if i should put it in
higher right
i mean coming into student loan debt you
mean you've got student loan debt
that'll be due
after you graduate it's yeah
i mean well i'll start my payments like
in 2023 yeah so how much student loan
debt do you have
um it'll be 22 000 okay
and are you uh are you still using
student loan debt for your junior and
senior year
yes okay like all together it'll be 22.
yeah how much is it now
uh 10. okay so what would happen if you
decided i'm gonna make the other 12
instead of going into debt
you got three right
how about taking out no more student
loans
that's an option yeah i'm busting you
bust your butt and pay cash for the rest
of it
gotcha and then and then i'm
through baby step two and then just
start oh you still got the 10 000
laying there that you've already taken
out right but we're just going to stop
doing damage as our first goal
and then when you graduate from school
you'll just attack the 10 000 with your
new job
you know uh that'll be a lot better than
any college job
hopefully and what are you studying
um i'm studying cedar performance and
then i have a double major in
business marketing okay so what is your
plan for your career
um i went to this uh place in new york
city called
theater theatrical rights worldwide and
they offered me a job out of college but
i kind of got to look into that and
salary wise so i'd be
um marketing and selling shows for a
company
cool sounds like you get to use
everything you've learned
yeah that would be neat okay cool
yeah and you don't know what it pays and
it's a ways out so you've got to button
that thing up between now and then but
in the meantime you've got to finish up
your junior and your senior year and
you've got to pay cash in your 9 000
short to do that that's right
and so you can do that though because
you found work you got you you're
rolling you see anything ken
i think dave's absolutely right i think
you're working really hard and if you
made
three to four thousand this summer uh
you know you keep doing that
you've got your 12 grand right there and
you're cashflowing your way through
college so yeah i'd work
really really hard i would not take any
more student loans you don't need it
you've got the ability to do it so just
stay the course here
no more student loan debt and you're
you're gold
i i love this i would look into the new
york thing i want you to be more clear
on what that looks like
you know you've been offered you need to
know right off the top of your head
insulin okay this is what it's going to
cost
to live there and run those numbers on
that before you decide to take that new
york job
yeah but i mean really we're talking
about and this is june
so yeah if if the junior year is this
fall
it's two years to come up with uh
uh nine thousand dollars that's that's
only about 400
a month that's exactly right i worked
full-time in college
i did too when i said full-time i mean
40 hours plus i mean i was busting it on
the weekends really hard
you know wasn't much of a week in life
but it worked yeah
it got me through it our day you didn't
have any choice but yeah
now it's called child abuse but yeah
chad's in uh louisiana hey chad how are
you
hey dave how are you guys doing today
better than we deserve what's up
that's it that's it hey i'm i'm new into
this i'm one week into
um putting all my finances together and
and and starting the debt free living
cool process
and um my question is is that about five
years ago or
explain a little bit five years ago we
decided to do we become full-time rvers
so we sold the house in houston
and um really freed up a lot of money
for us and then
we've been living that lifestyle and
also
we got to the point where i've got
pretty much
everything into the calculation sheet
and i was wondering
on my rv should i refinance that
and hopefully get a lesser note to add
more cash
towards my debt free living or should i
stay on the path of what the whole
thing's explaining to me
by almost six years i'll be debt free
i would stay on the path and i think
what you're going to find is
that that as you as you plow through
this the momentum is going to pick up
and you're probably going to get out of
that faster than you think
most people that see a six-year plan end
up with about a four-year plan when it's
over because intensity increases
as you get further down into this and
then you so what is your 10-year game
plan on housing are you going to be
rving for the next 10 years
all depends on the health uh we've
already
figured out that i'm at 55 and no
medications no
illnesses no issues at all hopefully
that
in 10 years what are you living on how
are you how are you just working remote
or what
yes sir i'm an independent rep and
self-employed
so i travel throughout the south central
united states
working with uh about 40 other reps as
their support
and um so it it doesn't pay me to have a
house
because we're always on the road and you
and your wife
you and your wife yes sir okay yes sir
all right
and you're enjoying this lifestyle so
far
tremendously okay good you don't like it
maybe you can hook up and leave
good yeah well i i think getting that rv
paid off as fast as you possibly can
i'm not sure if it's your baby step six
or not because it's your house
uh you could put it there if you want
how much do you owe on it
uh we're right at 113k yeah and so if we
pull that out of the equation you're
dead free in
a year and a half two years easy yeah
yeah so i think maybe it's your baby
step six as if you had a hundred and ten
thousand dollar mortgage
and you put it over there and then you
work the system that way have you got a
copy of the book the total money
makeover to show you how to do all this
that's going to be my next step we've
loaded the excel program and my next
step was getting the book because we
just found out about you through my
brother
last week very cool well i'll give you
one uh hold on madison will pick up and
we'll ship you a copy of the total money
makeover as our gift
uh if we can figure out where to ship it
to yeah that's that's gonna be the
hardest part of this
have fun brother we're honored to have
you as a new listener and a new member
of the tribe madison will ship you a
free copy just to say thanks for
listening
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
james charles is our producer and
madison is our associate producer and
phone screener i'm dave ramsey your host
and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america it's a free call
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five my co-host today
ken coleman of the ken coleman show
ramsey personality
number one best-selling author as he
talks about careers
finding your passion getting the right
kind of job
and even getting the promotion over at
the place you love
and you know ken it's been a natural
thing for the ken coleman show to
become wildly popular in a very short
period of time
because it's a subject that ramsay we've
been talking about for a long time
this whole idea that you know there's
the income side of the equation the
outgo side of the equation
and sometimes the problem is the outgo
side but sometimes the problem is the
income side
absolutely and when you think about
people who say all right i want to
increase my income they automatically
have this default
idea and it's really a myth well i'm
gonna have to go to school
and so i'm trying to get out of debt i
certainly can't take on tuition
i don't have the time on top of that and
that's a myth because we now know
that there are more and more ways than
ever dave to get qualified to actually
now begin
to be able to move up the ladder to make
that income that you want
and the impact that you want you know
this idea of just
working to pay the bills that's not what
anybody wants
inherently everybody knows that there's
more to life and we want to contribute
and so the idea of increasing our shovel
the big shovel that you've been talking
about for a long time
to get out of debt faster is one part of
the equation the other part is to do
work that matters
as we look out the glass of our studio
here on the giant
screen where our staff meets every
monday morning
it says do work that matters and that is
something that's a part of the fabric
here at ramsey solutions and we want to
help
everyone else that's listening do work
that matters to them
a job change doesn't you know you're
right
sometimes people think uh well that has
to come after i get out of debt
so that i've got the money to go to
school so i've got the money
but it doesn't have to cost money it
does not have to uh because a lot of
times it's just good old-fashioned
put yourself out there raise your hand
and say hey how can i
add these skills that would allow me to
step into this position and you'd be
surprised sometimes
that it doesn't require a degree or if
it does you'd be surprised how many
times companies who realize good people
and they'll say you know what we'll pay
for that so don't assume
that i've got to go to college and spend
money i don't have
in the time that i don't have while i'm
in baby step two you can do this while
you're getting out of debt
and i think that's what we're excited
about showing people that
more and more people are just looking
for quality companies looking for
quality people and they'll train them on
the job
i will tell you this i have not tracked
it to the dime
but anecdotally and i'm very very close
somewhere around 90 percent
of the people that come on the air here
in person or on the phone to do their
debt-free scream
have during the get out of debt journey
increased their income and
many times substantially yeah every time
i've heard a scream or seen a script
sometimes they increase it by extra jobs
oh yeah sometimes they increase it by
i just started paying attention so i ask
my boss for a raise uh
sometimes they increase it by um i
really wasn't shopping
but i realized doing what i do i can
make twice as much if i move over there
and doing the same thing and so they go
do that
and there's just like this kind of like
the veil was lit the fog
on the career thing was lifted and
you know sometimes they say oh i went
and finished up a certificate
or i i was this close to finishing my
degree so i did that and then that
launched me forward sure
sometimes they budget and pay cash for
the change to because it's going to
launch them forward that that happens
sometimes but most of the time that's
not the case no
and folks is getting qualified is stage
two of our
of our seven stages here and getting
promoted to stage five
in between there's get qualified i'm
getting connected i'm getting started
that's a switch if you will
or moving into something new but getting
promoted is many times
one of the fastest most effective ways
to get through the debt
snowball and then get into the baby step
three and pile up that emergency fund
and now
all of a sudden everything has changed
so we're really trying to help people
see the connection between wait a second
i've got talent and if i'm not doing
something that i really enjoy
there might be a deep connection between
ex uh
in in advancing professionally
and advancing financially i mean we've
got to see that it's not just getting
promoted for the sake of getting
promoted it's hey
i can make the income i need and the
impact i want
that's what we're doing on the ken
coleman show so it absolutely is a
wonderful tie-in
but i want to drive this point back home
don't assume
that you have to go to school and spend
a lot of money to get qualified that is
that
that is a careless assumption it might
be true in some cases
let's be very clear i mean there there
are still professions that require
a four-year degree and sometimes a
graduate degree and if you're going to
move over to that and you don't know
you've never taken an accounting class
and you want to be a cpa you're going to
go get your masters in accounting yeah
that's really not an option if you're
going to go be a licensed
uh therapist yep you're going to go get
a master's degree
in psychology at a minimum in every
state right in order to get licensed to
do that and so and if you've had no
classes then
you know you got a four maybe a five
year ride there that's right there's
graduate level work involved in those
two things
that i just mentioned but this idea that
um
you know i have to get i have to get my
mba to
uh to move up no you don't no yeah i
don't we get this call a lot of they can
call hey ken i want to move into
leadership
should i pursue an mba now an mba on its
own
is a wonderful achievement a lot of
wonderful things
good information it's knowledge that's
valuable knowledge
experience it certainly is impressive
but it is not table stakes
well it doesn't guarantee your
leadership spot you know
if you want to if you want to become a
leader well i would tell you to start by
listening to the entree leadership
podcast i'd start by telling you go to
some of those events
go to other leadership events read
leadership books and here's an idea
how about engaging with a leader at work
and say hey
i think i might want to lead one day how
can i get better as a follower
and these are all tactics that again
don't cost a lot of money
but qualify you more for leadership than
an mba does
by far by far and and so don't make the
assumption that i've got to go to school
which is going to cost me money i don't
have right now
and time i don't have don't assume that
dig into it the first one is
i have to quit my job and have no income
coming in
so i can go to school and spend the
money to do that yeah don't do that
that's the worst one
well certainly in 2021 where now you can
go
to school online in so many different
ways give an example
you know we've got a partner of the ken
coleman show bethel tech they're
training people
that have that have no experience you
can go from no technology experience at
all dave
to starting out making 75 000 a year
75 000 a year and then have the
opportunity two years later to go into a
six figure income
with the kind of people you were talking
about earlier today that we hire all the
time developers
i mean technology dave is now in every
industry in the world
health care non-profit religious
organizations
everybody's got technology jobs and
that's not going to change and you don't
need a four-year degree
to win in technology no no that's just
one example
absolutely interesting stuff ken coleman
the ken coleman show
be sure and check him out at
kingcoleman.com tons of information
there about opening up this
whole idea of a bigger shovel
what do you do to get your income up and
do it in such a way that your life is
better because when you go to work
you're smiling
you're doing work you love this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
um
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ramsey personality ken coleman is my
co-host today
xavier is with us in uh orlando florida
hi xavier how are you
how you doing sir good man what's up
yeah i have a question from my
my wife and i you know we just started
the baby step uh
one monday um
i was reading the book when i get to to
the part where it says
that i have to have all my bills current
so my question is before before we do
the thousand dollars we have to have all
the bills current
right my question is when you're so far
behind sir
how you make how you get to be current
okay that's a really good question
thank you for calling um it's not to say
you're punished but the baby steps don't
work while you're
got all these well you got these hornets
nest of bills chasing you right
so we got to get the things calmed down
to be able to work the baby steps so i
appreciate you a lot calling in
because that's where sharon and i found
ourselves a few years back is in that
same
situation okay what are you behind on
um uh one car
payment is a month two months behind you
know my life bill's a little bit behind
the insurance a little bit behind what
else
um that's about it to be honest with you
okay how much is your car payment
um i have one is 350
and the other one is five hundred
dollars what are you behind on the 500
actually you know the the the 350 yeah
yeah the the 500
yes sir okay all right and how about how
far behind are you on the electric
what's it take to get current
um about a month maybe one month
how much is that uh about two hundred
dollars
okay and what about the insurance is
this car insurance you're behind on
yes sir all right how far behind are you
on that and what's it take to get a
current money wise
it's going to take maybe 300 and some
357 dollars
okay cool all right so i got 500 200
and 350. i got a thousand bucks changes
your life
okay you see i did that yes sir
what do you guys make what's your
household income um between my wife and
i we make
uh 89 000 a year okay great news right
okay so here's what we're gonna do
you're gonna get on the online i'm gonna
give you
ramsey plus which will get you hooked up
to
the full the full thing man i'll put you
in a
financial peace university the class
that almost 10 million people have been
through
but most importantly for this discussion
it's going to put you into every dollar
the pr with the premium version where it
hooks to your bank account
to do your budget and you and your wife
are going to sit down tonight
and you're going to work on that budget
using that every dollar app okay
oh are you yeah i'm going to give you
the whole thing free
oh my because i really appreciate that
i've been where you are i've been scared
i remember how it feels how old are you
sir i'm not scared i am freaking out to
be honest with you
that's okay how old are you i'm 42 years
old
okay cool so here's what we're going to
do
the uh what you're going to do is you're
going to each
month you need to take the money
that you have coming in and give it an
assignment
before the month begins okay
so you've got pretty substantial money
coming in
in july and maybe another check in june
correct
yes sir okay so what does your take-home
pay look like a month
i get uh my take-home pay is 1600.
a month oh no a month uh no 1600 every
every two weeks okay so 3 200 for you
that means your wife's probably doing
uh two to three thousand as well right
yes sir
okay so i'm just gonna say six thousand
dollars just for an example
all right okay now what i want you to do
here's how you get current to answer
your original question
you're going to use this budget for or
this budget app tonight
to first thing you buy
before you buy anything with your six
thousand dollars for this coming month
is food before your family does anything
they gotta eat
agreed yes sir and so we're gonna put
down a budget for
food how many kids you got
oh we have no case in the house our kids
are gone and married
okay so no eating out you're broke and a
thousand dollars behind
you don't need to go to a freaking
restaurant agreed
yes sir so you're gonna go to the
freaking grocery store
and buy food and cook food at home
much much much cheaper okay
now and so given that for two people
let's just say
i'm gonna give i'm gonna be a little bit
up let's say you said eight hundred
dollars a month for food
that's high you can make it on less but
i'm giving you a little pad
four hundred dollars every two weeks
okay
yes sir you'll put that in every dollar
and i had six thousand dollars coming in
and so now i have five thousand two
hundred dollars left you're with me so
far
yes sir the second thing you pay is your
all your utilities including let's get
this electric bill current
okay so it's going to take 400 because
it's 200 behind and 200 for this month
to get the electric current then you got
to pay the water if you got gas you got
to pay that
whatever your utilities are your your
cable bill if you got a big buck cable
bill you need to cut it back and get
almost nothing
just enough to have internet or
something you're broke
we're trying to get out of being broke
you're in survival mode
for a short time and you're going to
live like no one else you're going to
live on nothing beans and rice rice and
beans
so that later you never have this stress
again does that sound like a good idea
yes sir you can do this man i can tell
i've talked to people for 30 years and i
can tell when somebody's ready and this
guy's ready ken
it's ready dave can we talk about the
car i'm curious to know how much the car
is worth that has the 500
payment attached to it getting there
fast yeah yeah so
so my my car my wife's car goes
um actually i have i have it written
down right here give me one minute i'm
sorry it's okay but no worries
uh my white car owes nineteen thousand
three hundred and seventy dollars
and my car owes thirteen thousand two
hundred and sixty five dollars
what's your car actually worth your car
to be honest with you i have no idea
what about hers
um i haven't even checked how much my
car is worth 500
car payment on 19 000 tells me you got a
screwed on the interest rate because you
got bad credit
yeah we are back ready and then we got
the car when i um
right after we did a a bankruptcy like
like
like almost 10 years ago and so that car
they jacked you you're paying 15 16
interest aren't you yeah so i have yeah
i
i did numbers on monday because i was
when i read your book i was like oh my
god
so we owe 84 321
and 40 000 of that is owed to the irs
okay is that on a payment plan
so i called the irs last week and then
submitted my paperwork
like two months ago and they still have
not received it so i don't even know
tell you when you get off get online at
get online at ramseysolutions.com and
click on tax
elp and find one of our tax providers to
help you get
an arrangement made for a payment plan
with the irs until you can get them paid
off but you need to get them on a
payment plan because they're going to
surprise you and come take stuff
like you're like your check yeah
they're going to come like a thief in
the night you don't want them doing that
so you got to
see what we're doing is we're getting
all of these monsters out from under the
bed and we're putting leashes on all of
them
so i think your wife's car is probably
going to be sold mainly because the
interest rate
is is just absolutely asinine
they're just killing you they're killing
you
and get you a cheap car because listen
here's the thing you make 80 000
a year you could be 100 debt free
irs and everything two years
i'm not talking about being current i'm
talking about debt free
in two years but you're going to have no
freaking life during that two years
and you're going to be driving a beater
and your wife's going to be driving your
old car because it's the nicest car and
the wife gets the good car
i my wife and i we want to do whatever
it takes or to
we we're just tired we're just tired
we're tired you're ready man you're
gonna do it
i'm going to show you exactly what to do
madison's going to pick up we're going
to get you signed up for financial peace
university and
all the goodies in every and all the
good every dollar all the goodies in
ramsey plus
and we are here xavier i want to hear
back from you while you're fighting on
this
you've got to have more questions you
call and talk to ken and me anytime and
we will help you with this process
i'm so proud of you you're why we're
here
[Music]
[Music]
logan is with us in louisville kentucky
hey logan how can ken and i help
[Music]
hey how you doing dave great man what's
up paul sure
so my dad passed away recently and i was
i was fortunate enough to receive a
pretty large inheritance
inside the inheritance was two ira
accounts
valued last week at around 430 000
and then there were two properties one
of them being
a house with a mortgage on it that my
grandparents were living in
his parents and uh they're paying the
mortgage on that so it's kind of out of
the equation
the other property is the house my dad
was living in
and it's uh it's completely paid off
and uh so i guess my question for you
dave is
you know i know the market's really hot
right now as far as real estate goes so
would it be smart to sell that uh
property
or you know should i start to learn how
to be a landlord and maybe rent that out
um
how old are you and i'm mark i'm 24
right now
again 24 sorry
24. oh my gosh how old was your dad
56 what happened
uh liver disease i'm so sorry you
yeah how long ago did he pass
it's been about three or four weeks now
i'm so sorry
were you all close yeah
so this is a debilitating process not a
sudden thing
and so you guys have had time to talk
and you knew this was coming
yeah yeah yeah and uh what's the how was
the house worth
here what's the house worth that your
grandparents live in
uh but i don't know for sure dave i want
to say around
200 000. it's in a very nice
neighborhood but it's only a one-story
house what's the uh
what do you think the mortgage is on it
do you remember
a little over a thousand i believe 100
000
uh yeah yeah is owed on the house and
they pay
around a thousand a month or something
like that right i got you
okay and the roughly the value of the
home he was living in
uh 250 000 roughly okay
all right uh um
do you own a home
i'm currently living with my girlfriend
she owns
you know a little eighty thousand dollar
house and uh i paid
half the mortgage do you have plans to
get married
uh yeah yeah i think so when
well neither of us are really too
concerned about it to be honest with you
dave so
uh you know it helps me with the timing
of these answers that's why i'm asking
okay
so because it changes what we do here so
all right um okay let me give you a
couple of principles that i use
the situations like this one when um
and these are running through my mind
while i'm trying to formulate my answer
okay principle number one is when you
are grieving
and the waves of grief are coming over
you none of us
including me think clearly
as we do when we're not grieving that's
logical right
so i try in these situations two three
weeks
into the process i try to not make
major financial decisions in the middle
of my brain being in a bit of a fog
okay great that's principle number one
that's running through my mind
the other piece of information i know is
is that an inherited ira
is going to require that you drain it
over a 10-year period of time
under current law so you're going to be
pulling
43 000 a year out of this
and paying taxes on it at a minimum
the law is going to require that okay
the other thing that's running through
my mind is uh if
ma if grandpa and granny are gonna stay
in that house that you now own
i assume there was a will
yeah okay that you now own or you will
own when probate is done because you're
gonna have to run this through
probate and you're going to have to have
an attorney to do the estate help you
with that stuff there's a process here
on these
properties to get them moved into your
name but
when you get the other side of that then
i'm going to want
grandpa and granny's house to be paid
off and
from something okay the third thing
that's running through my mind is
if you've never really had big
aspirations of being a landlord this is
not the time
don't become a landlord by default
by catapult okay
so uh there's no huge rush
but by this time next year i'm probably
selling the house that he's was in
and i'm going to use that money to pay
off grandpa's mortgage
and grandpa can pay you back or grandpa
can
live there for your choice i don't care
but i don't want that mortgage on there
because guess what that mortgage is your
problem it's not their problem
it's on your house so i want you to be
debt-free
and somewhere in this soup that we're
stirring up this gumbo that we're adding
ingredients to as i keep stirring here
is possibly you getting married and
buying a home
with some of this money with your new
wife but we're certainly not going to
pay off
someone else's mortgage that you're not
married to so you do
not pay her bills under any
circumstances
okay just uh some some background on
that dave
so i don't intend to live in this uh
not not the grandparents house but my
dad's house
my grandma actually died last year on my
mom's side
and she left a property to my mom
and it's out in the country and has an
acre and i think me and my girlfriend
were probably gonna move
there within the year so
as far as the uh okay so that
goes but i'm just saying i've got this
pile of cash and i can buy a house with
it if i need to
when i'm married is what's floating
around that's like step two
you know 2.0 version of 3.0 version of
this
strategy that we don't have to make all
these decisions today while you're still
crying okay
yeah it's okay to take your time you
don't there's no rush
if you don't put the house on the market
until the fall because you go through
and clean it
you have somebody clean it uh you give
yourself some time to breathe
and grieve and and that's just normal
human stuff
man you don't need to be like a robo or
a robot
robocop or something here with no
feelings
okay so i don't i mean obviously your
mom and dad are separated liver
indicates possible other things
and so you know there's all kinds of
stuff in this relationship
but all but it still hurts
yeah yeah so take your time uh
what i would do is have a plan with this
money
to be clearing off that mortgage and
getting that house that getting your
dad's house sold
within one year but towards the back of
the year
meaning a year from now okay in other
words after the first of the year put
the house on the market
after the first of the year get the
mortgage paid off or something along
those lines
you do need with the inherited ira to
sit down uh
in the next three or four weeks with a
smart vester pro click smart investor
pro at ramsey solutions that's someone
we recommend we're not in the investment
business but they can help you roll that
into some good mutual funds and they can
set up the mandatory drain
the 10-year drain that that is now
required by law
and set that up coming to you and you
can simply use
two years of that withdrawal to pay off
grandma granny's house over there if you
want to
because that's going to be very close to
that amount and if you'll not
touch any of this money and live off of
your income which you were doing prior
to his passing
then this is going to end up being a
huge financial windfall for you long
term
but give yourself some room to cry
brother
be normal okay it's um
people they feel like somehow they need
to be superman when it comes to money
and that's not right
[Music]
yep great advice to just heal and then
come out of the storm
and then follow the plan he's in great
shape he makes good decisions yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 17 17
a friend loves at all times and a
brother is born
for a time of adversity mother teresa
said
some people come into your life as
blessings other people come into your
life as lessons
good not the truth i have never heard
that one that is fabulous i'm thinking
about my kids right now she is so sweet
i'm thinking about people that are not
as nice as your kids
that's true too peak real estate season
is just around the corner this year
things are different home prices are
higher competition between
buyers is intense man
you can make a six-figure mistake
screwing around out there in real estate
right now don't
jump headfirst into something you don't
understand if you don't know where to
start
you're not financially ready for a
mortgage if you don't have questions
if you have questions about how to buy
or sell get with a pro start by
connecting with one of our endorsed
local providers these are high octane
high protein agents that actually know
what the flip they're doing they sell a
lot
of houses it's not amateur hour out
there right now boys and girls
if you're selling a house when
everybody's giving you multiple bids
above
asking price 50 of the homes in america
sold above asking price
in may wow first time in history you
don't want
you don't want a rookie agent managing
multiple offers above this
this is uh this is someone who knows how
to juggle the flaming swords
you need to be have somebody knows how
to do it go to ramseysolutions.com
agent if you're going to list a house
right now this is a great time to sell a
house
horrible time to do it with a rookie
horrible time i know that your aunt
sally just got her license i don't give
a crap
your aunt sally doesn't know what she's
doing she's sweet
you can have her bake cookies but don't
ever sell your house
that's ridiculous if she didn't sell 300
houses last year 50 houses last year
let's not talk about it
never sold a house in her life she's
going to list yours dumb idea
ramsay solutions dot com slash agent get
with one of our endorsed local providers
they'll help you do it
right victoria is with us in boston
hi victoria how are you hi gabe i'm
doing great i'm so excited to talk to
you
you
too what's up in your world um
well i got married seven months ago and
me
and my husband are wondering if there is
a rule of thumb or a percentage of our
take-home or gross income that we should
be saving towards a baby fund
what's a baby fund like um
i know that you tell people when they
learn that they're expecting to store
away you know as much money as they can
we have a plan where we don't want to
get pregnant for seven years which is a
whole
story but um in those seven years we're
going to pay off our house so i can stay
home with the kids
wow okay you do not need a baby
you do not need a baby fund you need an
emergency when i tell people to stop
doing their
baby steps it's because they don't have
any money saved
and i don't want them working paying off
debt and have
no money while they're pregnant that's
what it is god sure well we already have
our emergency fund yeah
i bet i can tell you guys you guys are a
wee bit into planning
but yeah a little bit yeah my husband
turned me on too long ago before we got
married and was a requirement that i
took financial peace before we got
married
wow hardcore okay well i'm honored i
appreciate that so yeah
i think if you have your emergency fund
and you're doing your investing and
you're building up wealth to pay
pay off the house or pay cash for a
house or whatever your plan is
there i think you're gonna have plenty
of money to buy some diapers if you need
to
i thought so i just didn't know if there
was a rule of thumb well thank you so
much
thank you i appreciate the call very
cool eric is in cincinnati hi eric
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you for taking my call sir how are
you sure better than i deserve what's up
hey uh so just a quick question for you
i'm 26.
i just finished baby step three i have
no debt
i make 20k a year not very much i have
two years in college and my rent
uh next baby step was doing uh
retirement at 50
15 for retirement is that something i
should be doing right now or should i be
focusing another thing
you said you have two years of college
yeah um i dropped out after two years
my parents for fortunate enough giving
me some money uh
student loans cover the rest and okay so
you're you're 20.
right you make twenty thousand
adam 26 correct 26 and you make 20 000 a
year
okay so what are your career plans
i i'm a golf professional right now that
was that was when i was majoring in
college so that's you know if you
that's why i stopped going to college um
but yeah you know i'm i'm a teacher
professional i've grown up uh playing
golf on my life it's what i love doing
but you know right at some point i gotta
gotta make those life decisions are you
a teaching pro
is that what you mean when you're a
professional correct okay right kid
checking why are you only making twenty
thousand dollars
uh i it's i'm on salary for two thousand
a month
um you know after taxes is about 17.50
and you know just what it is you kind of
have to
get your way through in that yeah you
don't get paid per lesson or anything
that that's like they call that tips you
know more or less but yeah
probably about what sixty dollars a
lesson so yeah it's nice
it's a little something but you know to
say that but you're not doing many
lessons
yeah i've written about five weeks five
or six you probably about once a day to
me twice
i don't understand how you're only
making twenty thousand dollars um
i've got friends that are teaching pros
that are making really good money
teaching
uh with lessons yeah right i i
most of my hours are in the shop you
know i'd say i'm doing it being a
teasing professional it's not
yeah it's not mine okay so you're all
primary job there but
yeah i i do about eight to ten hours in
the shop and then sometimes in the
mornings
yeah and i teach all right what's the
next rung on the ladder because uh
it's been a while since i've talked to
somebody who's doing this you're in the
shop
basically minding the pro shop and then
you're doing a little bit of extra
teaching for not
much 60 bucks a lesson so what's the
next step up what's that look like
financially
it'd be it'd be a it'd be a head pro or
you know you're doing teaching all the
time and
what you're thinking but you know right
i'm more calling to ask is to say
you know hey you know should i should be
doing a new career patch or go back to
school
you know that that kind of thing no no
no if you want to if you want to be a
golf pro no you don't need to go back to
school i mean you're already in
this is a it's a pay your dues business
much more so than
than a lot of industries you got to kind
of slog
and you know how political it is too you
kind of got to look for an opening
somewhere else
because it's probably a long shot that
the guy who's the head pro now is going
to just up and leave
so you're going to have to be head on a
swivel very aggressive
networking connecting like crazy because
it is very hard to get a head pro job
right yeah you're starving to death and
unless you put in place a plan
to move up this ladder yes you do need
to do something different yeah and you
don't sound very intense about it
you sound kind of flippant about it when
you're talking about it i'm
i'm i'm pretty happy with how my life is
going um
you know i'm always seeking new
opportunities uh but you know i'm i'm
not even working right now but building
a resume in a sense i mean if you want
to say no then fine but
you know okay yeah you need to start
saving 15
of your income but you need to work on
your income
yeah that's what it comes down to you're
not making much money and you need to
gain
you need to have some kind of a goal for
your life
that when you're 36 you're not making
the same that you're making when you're
26.
yeah i you know what dave normally calls
me nice guy i'm not going to be so nice
here this is i know this industry my
brother started in it now as a
division three head golf coach you are
nothing more
than an assistant manager of a pro shop
and you got a little bit of teaching
if you call yourself a teaching pro then
you need to get
really jacked up about teaching lessons
because if you teach
lessons uh in a well you know nice
community like cincinnati ohio a lot of
golf there ohio is a big golf crazed
state
if you really really wanted to make more
money this is about you getting serious
about lessons where you can get
really good pay but i'm with dave i
don't think you're fired up
i think you're enjoying your life and
you're comfortable but here's the
reality don't say you're teaching pro
when you're not you're minding the golf
store
and and and checking people in for their
tee times
so you got to decide what is it that you
really want to do but this idea of i'm
going to go back to school for a better
career well you don't even know what you
want to do yet
and so there's some decision making for
you right now
and this is a pretty pivotal point in
your life at 26.
even if you go back to school after you
get the degree you still have to get up
leave the cave and kill something drag
it home
that's right and that that's what's
struggling in this conversation
so you like your life the way it is i
you know save 15
of your income but dude if you make 20
000 the rest of your life
you know you're you're gonna struggle
period
i mean you're going to be at the poverty
level that's what it amounts to
[Music]
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books thanks to ken coleman my
co-host today
james childs my producer in madison our
associate producer and phone screener i
am dave ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you